hey guys how's it going good um how's
going with you going great so if you
can't tell I'm at home right now with
Jenna hi so I made this awesome
stop-motion video of kind of my date
this is part 2 of the stop-motion video
because a lot of you guys were asking me
about the headphones these are the
turtlebeach i60 series they also have
the i30 series but the i6 jeez come with
this little guy it's like a little media
and my favorite part
Jenna's just keeps on turning down like
no stop no touch I'm like pretty and
shiny it's on some you right now oh oh I
bet no what are you gonna make me do I
could probably call you and do voice
morph I see a future pranking video I
see a future video we're gonna do right
now let's do my little game for okay oh
wait what game I'm going to say things
into the microphone and you'll hear it
in your head you didn't tell me about
the game yes so you're gonna try not to
laugh put them on your head that's okay
I'm gonna say something to you we'll see
I don't know what you're saying just my
cackle is excellent hold on wait a
minute let me put some more sounds in it
okay I was wondering if you would like
some pumpkin pie with that cheesecake
tonight for dinner
this one is thick in here right it
sounds like a man yeah okay
let me blow to this to my phone call
Jenna is this a chipmunk I'm sorry I was
expecting a call from a voice more for
oh hi there you are hello
I do like pumpkin pie in castles
this would be less creepy if it wasn't
your name coming up on my phone this is
like a replay of what just happened oh
my god it's so funny alright guys thanks
for watching you felt more information
about the headphones link in the
description if you haven't seen the
stop-motion video please go check it out
cuz it's one of the probably my most
favorite videos I've ever made it is a
pretty good video and sadly it did not
hit the YouTube subscription box as some
of you said some of you saw it some of
you didn't so go check it out and I'll
see you guys in the next video let me
know uh who we should call and maybe
order a pizza